[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I cannot believe how many
comments we've been getting about the
topic of this video and how many people
wanted to see a video about it and I
can't blame you because I too was going
crazy about the fusion between Kusaka
and Chandler otherwise known as the
center or the original demon
alternatively translated as the first
demon if you guys want to see more
videos like this one make sure to let me
know by smashing down like button and
subscribe and ring that magic youtube
bell if you want merlin to teleport
future 7 Deadly Sins videos straight to
your phone and if you just can't get
enough 7 Deadly Sins content make sure
to follow us on instagram and twitter at
anime uproar you can find the link in
the description and if you still feel
like praising the sun you can go to
anime upper calm and get yourself an
Eskin or praise the sun shirt and share
in Eskin ors glory and support the
channel at the same time fans of the
channel can get 25% off
just use the code uproar 25 at checkout
obviously if you haven't figured it out
yet
there will be cutting edge spoilers in
this video we're literally talking about
the most up-to-date chapter so you've
been warned so let's recap what happened
in chapter 2 9 2 just as Merlin had
cusack where she wanted him the memories
of Esther Rose destroyed then and he
began flooding back to Maryland which
seems to hurt her mind and distract her
giving Cusack the chance to escape from
her grasp lunar shell seems to be in
much more pain which makes sense since
esta rosa used to be his own little
brother mile so he would take it harder
than most eskimo returns to his buff
form because the Sun that was charged in
Rita the realization of the truth about
mile came to most as a shock and
impacted them right in their very souls
and the closer someone was to him the
greater the impact zelgius is funny here
because he's completely fine and says he
never once looked up to a serosa as a
brother but is in fact relieved which is
hilarious so just a surprise when Cusack
asks him to
we've a recovered eScan or an Merlin
who's the true power seems bottomless to
himself in Chandler he thinks it's time
to strike but Cusack wants him to
preserve his power for when the other
sins come cusack and Chandler say this
is their duty and they touch staffs
which initiates the fusion lucky didn't
have to do a fusion dance but seriously
there's so much Rangel influence in the
seven deadly sins that's seeing two
characters fuse even if they were one
before doesn't surprise me knock about
the mangaka have said in the past that
he was influenced by Dragon Ball and
that Dragon Ball is one of the reasons
he loves drawing muscles and his
characters and the fact that characters
have power levels is probably an
influence from Dragon Ball 2 more on the
similarities between Dragon Ball into
seven deadly sins later but let's get
back to this fusion they say that once
long ago in order for the demon king to
rule over the underworld he created one
certain demon naming it the original
demon the demon king granted it his
power as his most trusted retainer but
the sinful demon of origin took great
hubris in his own strength and Sirte
rebellion to take the demon King's
throne for his own of course after
overtaking the demon it receives a great
and dire punishment its entire body and
soul was torn into two and it was given
an important duty they were to be the
instructors to the two princes and to
raise them to be candidates for the next
demon king then they turned into their
original form the form of the sinner the
original demon and Merlin says as of now
the gang has lost all chance of victory
we also got bond returning and the manga
tells us he returned with the strength
he gained in purgatory so you can bet
he's gonna get an upgrade and we have
Mellie Otis set to come back as well
this chapter was absolutely insane and I
can't wait for the next one but let's
have some fun and focus on the original
demon for now as we wait for it to come
if we remember back to chapter 247 the
demon Kings supposedly split his
strength in half and granted it to his
servant but the power was so great that
even threatened his own position so he
devised a much safer method of
controlling the demon world without ever
granting any one person too much power
and so the ten commandments were born
each having a fragment of the demon
Kings pow
at first I thought this original demon
would be a throwaway line
I completely forgot about this first
servant until now but it appears that
this servant was none other than the
fusion of Cusack and Chandler
so the original demon got half of the
demon Kings power level some of you
suggested in the comments that the demon
king might have split his power in half
twice once when he gave the power to the
original demon and again when he gave
the power to the Ten Commandment if that
were the case and he didn't recover any
power back from the original demon but
just split him in two then the demon
Kings power might originally be even
greater than at first thought we were
discussing the possibility in the all
power levels ranked video of every
commandment representing a power level
of 28,000 because Esther OSA rose from
60,000 to 88000 after gaining one more
commandment some of you said that that
theory would make a land have a negative
power level since this total is 27,000
but remember he can go up to 40,000 in
critical / mode so perhaps you can you
his weaker mode as a way of hiding /
saving power while his stronger mode
better utilizes his commandant again
this theory might be incorrect because
the 10 portions of the demon Kings power
might not be equal or they may grow
exponentially when added together more
on that later
but I just wanted to address it anyways
here for fun hypothetically if that were
the case then the demon Kings power
would have been 28,000 times 10 the
number of Commandments 10 times 2 which
equals 560 thousand now if we know we
split his power once before then we are
looking at an original power level of 1
million 120,000 that would make the
original sinners power level at least
500 60,000 if the demon king gave him
about half of his power since we don't
know how strong the sinner originally
was however let's approach the power
level of the original demon from another
angle we know that cusack has a power
level of 168,000 and that Chandler has a
power level of 173,000 before they are
empowered by the night-time which
according to Chandler makes a demon all
the stronger I saw some comments that
simply added these two power levels
together saying that the original demon
had a power level of 341,000 perhaps
this is correct and in the night time it
would rise to five hundred and sixty
thousand which would go with the twenty
eight thousand power level per
commandment theory this is one
possibility however another is what I
mentioned in the previous video what if
the demon Kings different powers don't
simply add up when put together what if
they grow exponentially I read recently
that the fusion between Goten and Trunks
their results in gold tanks doesn't
simply add their two power levels it
multiplies them so go tanks this power
level is go tens power level multiplied
by trunks is power level since as I
mentioned we know for a fact that the
seven deadly sins was influenced by
Dragon Ball in many ways perhaps this is
the key to how we should go about power
scaling the original demon rather than
simply adding their powers we might have
to multiply them so 173 thousand times
one hundred sixty eight thousand now we
are entering figures that are
practically worth being called
unmeasurable since the power level would
be twenty nine billion sixty-four
million I mentioned in the last video
that on page 149 of volume 15 of the
manga there's a special page of the
manga where we are told that there was
an example of a mutated species of gray
demon existing in the past with a combat
class beyond measure again I didn't
think too much of this like I didn't
think too much of the demon Kings
servant until one of you in the comments
mentioned that this mutated gray demon
could be the one that the demon king
gave half of his power to if the power
level is in the billions I get way would
be called unmeasurable since so far we
only measured power levels as far as 200
1000 again just the theory but it's an
interesting one so the point of this
video wasn't to come up with a
definitive answer for the power level of
the original demon which is impossible
with the information we have now but
since a lot of you guys were curious I
wanted to spark a discussion with some
possibilities let me know in the
comments will you believe there is no
doubt that this power level is gonna be
ridiculous since the usually cool-headed
Merlin even said that they have lost all
chances of victory even with her
bottomless magic and Eskin ores amazing
strength since she said lost all chances
of victory
she could even be suggesting that even
if the other sins arrived they would
still have no chance of winning since
that would be in the realm of
possibility all I know for sure is that
this manga is getting so crazy right now
I enjoyed this chapter so much and I'm
sure the next one is gonna be just as
interesting and will hopefully get some
power levels too the only issue is that
the chapters are so good that you breeze
through them without noticing and then
you have to wait another excruciating
week to know what happens next anyways
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video as
we wait together for the next amazing
chapter again we can't take any of these
theories too seriously because they are
only that theories but I hope that we
can get some good discussions going in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video definitely smash that like button
to let me know and subscribe and ring
that magic YouTube Bell so Merlin can do
her thing you can now pick up your very
own praise the Sun Eskin or t-shirt at
Anime uproar calm link in the
description it's only for hardcore Sun
Prazeres and fans of the channel can get
25% off by using the code uproar 25 at
checkout and remember if you just can't
get enough 7 Deadly Sins content you can
always follow us on instagram and
twitter at anime uproar link for
everything in the description and until
next time see you Sun Prazeres
[Music]
you